I am here to help eliminate the stigma
of medical cannabis thank you guys for
coming on this cold bristan I would like
to begin by telling you a little bit of
information about myself seniors many of
them almost all of them are dealing with
issues like insomnia anxiety depression
chronic pain various different types of
skin ailments aches and pains and
cannabis is tremendously effective for
all of these conditions and at the same
time I recognized that there were not
that many seniors who were accessing
medical cannabis in California cannabis
I didn't know that word I guess I'm 82
and a half and maybe a sheltered life
somewhat I didn't know anything about it
just through my children slipping and
sliding but that's about it we realized
that you have to that when you're
dealing with a population of people who
grew up in a period of time when stigma
around cannabis and ignorant and the
lies about cannabis were at their very
height that we are going to have to send
a trusted messenger in to deliver this
message and very fortuitously around the
same time I met sue Taylor and Sue was
obviously the perfect fit for this job
long before sue had encountered cannabis
or thought about cannabis as a medicine
she had dedicated herself to an
alternative approach to senior health
care a more holistic approach to senior
health care she had made it her personal
mission to help other seniors get off of
the wide range of pharmaceuticals that
almost any seen you talk too much to
anybody over 65 years old and there's a
list of medications that they're taking
and very often the side effects from
those medications are worse than the
symptoms that they're supposedly
treating and Sue recognized this many of
them on like 20 different pills they
know deep in within their heart
something is not working
they just don't know what I was taking
pills for high blood pressure diabetes
cholesterol pains in the knee headaches
just pills for everything managing
symptoms what pharmaceutical drugs has
kept us locked in a box and has robbed
us of the joy and the happiness that
that's was given to us by our Creator
members of Sue's family introduced her
to the idea of using cannabis for
medicine which was alien to Sue she had
been a Catholic school principal she had
been the most respectable of respectable
ladies in Oakland it didn't enter her
sphere to consider cannabis as medicine
but when her beloved family members
brought it to her she had enough respect
for them to take it seriously I did the
research I read everything he gave me I
studied up Harborside and I saw the
benefits of medical cannabis as a
medicine I had a lot of aches and pains
and all kinds of problems and someone
let me try their cream and I didn't know
cannabis came in a cream there's so much
I didn't know what I'm still learning so
I tried some
that worked very good for me and I also
tried some cookie and that was nice too
and that helped with the aches and pains
and headaches I had bad headaches oh it
helps me all over all over my skin my
weight makes you happier
it doesn't make you sleepy it doesn't
give you the headache I have been on
beautifu tall for many years along with
the value and the Irish moss and the
lotions on my temples have totally taken
away my migraine headaches I haven't had
a migraine a real migraine and maybe
three years the codeine was it was the
major problem because if I took a whole
codeine in the evening the next morning
I couldn't function well and I have to
in my job and the marijuana if I smoked
marijuana in the evening after I get
home from work it relaxes me and it
takes away the pain of the arthritis and
I can get some sleep at night more and
more people are choosing the cannabis
for inner life process rather than
morphine or some of those highly drugs
because they're present they're present
when they go over to the other side
they're present with their families
until they leave when they're on the
other hardcore drugs they're not present
they die long before they actually
physically bury medical marijuana is
about the safest drug you can on the
planet I think that's been determined by
a lot of responsible people and I think
that the senior citizens and need to
consider using and trying medical
marijuana opposed as opposed to some of
these other drugs cannabis is the way to
go it really is a great alternative I've
been a happy camper it's working good
for me I don't take pills
you know I don't and my life is
wonderful and yours can be too